so I think a lot about the idea of the
creative process right like what happens
to human consciousness when he is in a
state of cognitive genesis and a new
idea is being birthed and we hear a lot
of people use the term no my writer get
out of your own way the only thing
getting in your way is you
you know people talk about getting into
these flow states that silence the inner
critic you know the lateral prefrontal
cortex that is responsible for self
editing goes dim when you enter these
liminal trance states of heightened
creativity and
manic geometries of association thoughts
where you decondition they
and you know there is a kind of no-mind
when this happens you know I tell people
that making artists like a kind of
exorcism you have to die and be reborn
then when you are resurrected then
you're like wow look what I brought back
look at my canvas this is where I went
you know our painting our songs our
stories their maps for where we went
it's the equivalent of us like dropping
little pebbles behind us as we trail
towards new modalities of thought the
art is evidence the art is what we
brought back what we transmuted from the
other dimension to share with everyone
else to share with ourselves to
integrate right to upgrade ourselves to
expand the parameters of what is
as far as we can tell
you